[Musique]
vous savez que la compil de baba qui
sort le 22 septembre et je rappelle que
cette compil est très très importante
puisque il y aura un euro qui sera
reversée aux anges de la rue qui font
beaucoup pour toutes les personnes qui
sont dans la rue donc ce que je propose
c'est qu'on fasse un petit blind test
avec kelly sur les chansons à il y a
dans un conflit la compil de pas entrer
la tension pour répondre les chéris faut
mettre le pied comme ça non seulement
sportif mais également mais le premier
titre
je suis chaud non non lewiston cedef pas
ses torts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'artiste chocolat
ne prêtez pas la table c'est limite s'il
faut que je passe chez care ce soir
n'est pas tant l'accueil sur ma route
non la largeur de la chaussée bien que
j'espère donjon tiens tiens
[Applaudissements]
on est voulait ma famille c'est bon
c'est la vie
[Musique]
je
après la comédie tragédie bal pour tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les matins
tu me réponds ce cas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]